A falta de resultados definitivos todo
apunta a que el partido Colorado va a
ganar de nuevo estas elecciones durante
todo el conteo el candidato de este
partido Santiago Peña ha estado por
delante de su contrincante Efraín alegre
con una gran ventaja por el momento
incluso de 15 puntos recordamos que en
76 años de historia el partido Colorado
solo ha perdido las elecciones en
Paraguay en una única ocasión todo
parece Mostrar que los paraguayos han
decidido apostar por la continuidad y no
se han dejado distraer por las críticas
al presidente del partido Colorado
Horacio cartes que han sido acusado por
el gobierno de los Estados Unidos de
corrupción Eso sí un porcentaje
importante de paraguayos ha apostado Por
paraguayo Cuba es el candidato
antisistema que capitaliza el
descontento to aparte es la población
que no se ve representada por Ninguno de
los partidos tradicionales es todavía
pronto para cantar Victoria pero aquí en
la sede donde está el partido Colorado
ya ha empezado la patucada ya se ven
como ganadores habrá que esperar los
resultados definitivos para anunciar
Quién va a ser el próximo presidente de
Paraguay
[Música]